[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv 78 pour ce
premier club de la presse 2021 avec mes
confrères des médias locaux nous vous
souhaitons bien évidemment une
excellente année participent aujourd'hui
justement à cette émission alexandre
marqué journaliste 7,8 actus.fr et
toutes les nouvelles
bonjour alexandre - de l'or nicolas
kirillovitch journaliste pour radio
sensations 98.4 bonjour nicolas
bonjour bonjour également à noah dinh
anh journaliste à radio marmite 88.4
depuis trappe
bonjour nouradine bon jean wilfrid
bonjour à toutes et tous et puis vous
l'avez aperçu aussi nous avons un invité
que je vous présenterai dans un instant
tout d'abord voici lé titre le
gouvernement vient d'annoncer une
nouvelle série de mesures pour freiner
la hausse de l'épidémie couvre feu avant
ces protocoles sanitaires une nouvelle
fois renforcé dans les écoles quels
seront les grands dossiers à suivre en
2021 reprise économique nouvelles
élections dans les régions et les
départements mais aussi premiers
préparatifs pour 2024 et les jeux
olympiques et puis le nom d'olive linois
de l'année vient d'être dévoilée ce sont
les lecteurs de 7,8 actus.fr et de
toutes les nouvelles qui l'ont désigné
jonas de la lande il est agriculteur à
magny les hameaux invités de cette
édition
pour débuter ce club de la presse nous
avons donc un invité jonas de la lande
bonjour bonjour vous êtes agriculteur à
magny les hameaux ce sont les lecteurs
de toutes les nouvelles et de 7,8
actus.fr qui ont pris part au vote pour
vous désignez yvelinois de l'année 2020
alexandre marqué tout d'abord un mot sur
ce concours qui a été organisé par votre
publication comment ça s'est déroulé
qu'elle est un peu les candidats
en fait chaque année depuis 2015 donc le
journal toutes les nouvelles et les
corps et les il est né et notre star
être 118 actu on propose aux internautes
d'élire divinement de l'année les
lecteurs les internautes
il avait lui jusqu'au 6 janvier pour
voter parmi 20 candidats qui représente
la générosité la solidarité et le
travail d'altruisme et donc parmi ces
candidats vingt candidats il y avait
donc jeunes à la langue qui l'a emporté
donc un jeune agriculteur devoir parler
de salaire de magny les hameaux
il l'emporté donc avec 18 59% des voix
et devant un boulanger de maisons
laffitte ce type simoneau qui avait aidé
des soignants qui avait tu leur avait
offert des décroissants et puis devant
die die et diakité qui est président
d'une association de solidarité mali
limoux nous qui se trouve à plaisir et
des profils très différents chaque année
ils sont lauréats
oui oui depuis 2015 on a eu des profils
très différents mais souvent ce que je
disais à jonas quand je l'avais
interviewé souvent des saint quentinois
le premier à l'avoir emporté ça a été
mustapha larbaoui donc ancien président
du club de foot de trappes pour toutes
les actions de solidarité ou de civisme
de citoyenneté qui l'a mené au sein de
son association ou au sein de pharma
citoyens on a eu christian couturier
aussi un chirurgien de l'hôpital de
trappes qu'avec resto esma et puis l'an
dernier un autre profil très différent
duo scaramozzino
c'est dur à dire un champion de la pizza
acrobatique voyez rien à voir des
profils très différents et qu'on voit
d'ailleurs sur quelques images
d'illustrations qui passent en même
temps le maestro de la pizza profils
très différents et cette année donc
c'est jonas de la londe peut être
quelques mots avec lui
justement déjà première question
satisfait en tant que lauréat
félicitations vous êtes heureux de cette
distinction
mais merci beaucoup c'est une vraie
surprise je vais très très content et
c'est surtout très motivant pour tous
les projets le monde ans et tous les
projets que l'on a donc c'est surtout
très motivant d'avoir une telle
reconnaissance
alexandre vous passe la main oui j'ai
menace
vous avez repris la ferme familiale à
manier un mot il ya deux ans est ce que
vous le rappeler un peu votre parcours
comme en être arrivé parce que vous êtes
assez jeune 31 ans
comment on devient un agriculteur 29 ans
ah ben là c'est surtout de
belle histoire de famille je suis la
cinquième génération de la famille à
reprendre la ferme donc de mon arrière
grand père jusqu'à moi l'année dernière
et c'est une transmission qui se fait de
génération en génération
avec toujours une volonté de rester à
localiser si on a dit la roë
d'entretenir le patrimoine local sur
lequel on est très attaché et c'est
quelque chose dont vous avez toujours
rêvé c'est ce que vous alliez expliquer
exactement et depuis tout petit j'ai
toujours été sur les tracteurs avec mon
père je me voyais pas faire autre chose
avant de reprendre la ferme j'ai quand
même voulu travailler dans d'autres
entreprises pour connaître un petit peu
autre chose c'est vrai qu'après qu'on
ait installé sur une exploitation on
peut plus vraiment bougé donc c'était
l'occasion de voir ailleurs et donc j'ai
pu travailler à droite à gauche
et puis m'installer l'année dernière
suite au départ en retraite de mon père
des deux autres journalistes qui sont
avec nous aussi
nicolas nouradine vous y voyez quoi dans
cette victoire de jeunesse en retour
aussi aux valeurs de la terre
d'agriculteurs qui l'emportent en 2020
sur une période de situation sanitaire
compliqué où on cherche aussi des
circuits courts pour s'alimenter les
choses comme ça on aura du roi que le
son coupé mennour à nous de ton plus que
d'être un jeu peut-être enchaîné oui
c'est vrai que vous lisiez memory stick
ce que c'est une belle reconnaissance
pour le monde agricole on sait que c'est
pas toujours facile pour eux et ce
depuis de nombreuses années ils n'ont
pas toujours une image positive auprès
de auprès de tout le monde et on voit
avec cette crise que ben on le savait
déjà mais ils sont ils sont essentiels
et que le retour à la terre dont vous
parliez c'est important les gens ont
cette envie et ça passe forcément par
nos agriculteurs locaux donc c'est une
récompense juste et logique et j'espère
que cette image qui s'améliore de leur
travail et de leur personne va continuer
à s'améliorer
nadine oui pour rebondir sur ce que dit
nicolas c'est vrai qu'après le premier
confinement on avait quand même senti
que globalement dans le pays il y avait
une grande reconnaissance à l'égard des
agriculteurs après une longue période
d'agrippa chine comme on l'appelle
même si il me semble que ce sont pas
forcément des agriculteurs comme jonas
qui sont qui sont visés quand il ya des
critiques c'est plus à mon avis
l'agriculture de masse industriels qui
fait qui fait peur aux français et aux
françaises et du coup c'est vrai qu'il
ya une vraie envie de retourner vers les
acteurs de proximité
on a ça c'est ce qu'on a ressenti en
tout cas sur le terrain vous avez ouvert
une boutique un garde-manger on avait
quelques images on avait l'occasion
aussi pour tv 78 de venir vous voir il
ya eu un labyrinthe de maïs aussi pour
une partie plus ludique cette fois-ci
quels sont vos différents projets bon
ben c'est surtout de réitérer le
labyrinthe de maïs l'année prochaine ça
prend beaucoup de temps
et puis capitaliser suite à l'ouverture
avec succès du magasin continuer sur
cette lancée et continuer toujours avoir
des nouveaux produits des produits frais
en direct des producteurs c'est ce qui
nous tient à coeur et au local au
maximum concernant la crise sanitaire
économique aussi actuelle vous avez des
inquiétudes particulières ce qui vous
concerne pour votre exploitation non pas
à pas vraiment lié au contexte actuel de
toute façon on aura toujours besoin de
manger ça c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
pourra pas se passer on a la chance
d'être bien situés ont produit des
produits de qualité donc là dessus je
suis pas inquiet c'est plus la météo
face à nouveau nos problématiques
agricoles mais qui reviennent tous les
ans c'est plus ça qui nous perturbe ses
voix l'année dernière mais une très
mauvaise année
cette année ça se présente bien et ça
peut encore tout perdre au printemps si
la météo n'est pas bonne c'est ça qui
est le plus frustrant
alexandre le disais tout à l'heure vous
êtes un jeune agriculteur est ce que
aujourd'hui vous avez le sentiment que
de plus en plus comme vous des plus
jeunes s'intéressent à ces professions
la raho envie de de s'impliquer de
devenir eux aussi agriculteur près
j'étais assez surpris donc il est pour
s'installer en agriculture il faut faire
un parcours et notamment à une réunion à
la chambre d'agriculture qui nous
explique comment s'installer et je
pensais pour tout les yvelines pas qu'on
serait que 2 ou 3 et en fait on était
plus de 40 personnes dans le dans la
pièce et c'était beaucoup des personnels
et des urbains qui vous ont envie envie
de
je vis de se lancer dans l'agriculture
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une vraie
demande
après c'est pas facile comme métier
certains idéalistes un petit peu le
métier
merci je suis à qui une volonté comme ça
de d'avoir de se lancer dans
l'agriculture et votre quotidien alors
vous dites il aidé à lise un petit peu
certains le métier quel est le quotidien
d'un agriculteur votre quotidien c'est
quoi lever très tôt coucher très tard et
pas de vacances
non c'est un peu bête au château souvent
les agriculteurs
enfin on se lève tôt parce que moi j'ai
les premiers camions qui arrivent le
matin à 6h30 pour le magasin donc c'est
les producteurs qui nous lie feu très
tôt aussi parce qu'après ils ont une
journée de dans les champs à faire et
après bas surtout c'est ma femme qui
s'occupe du magasin et après je m'occupe
mois plus de la de l'exploitation et ça
dépend de la de la saison effectivement
pendant les périodes de moisson de semis
qui sont des grosses saisons là on va
travailler jusqu'à cet art mais on va
passer quelques mois dans l'année
le problème dans l'agriculture là où on
idéalise c'est surtout qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'heures de travail pour un
revenu auquel on n'a aucune idée en
permanence quoi c'est vraiment l'inconnu
c'est ça le plus dur jeunesse de la
lande yvelinois de l'année pour 7,8
actus.fr toutes les nouvelles qui est
notre invité pour ce club de la presse
alexandre si vous souhaitez poser une
dernière question étant encore un mot
sur ce concours ou un mois jonas oui ce
qu'on peut dire jonas c'est bien ça
c'est que le magasin depuis qu'il a
ouvert il marche très très bien
à tel point que vous avez recruté des
employés oui on a pu créer deux emplois
de cdi est également à prendre deux
apprentis avec nous donc ça nous soulage
beaucoup et ça nous fait vraiment
plaisir déjà de transmettre et de
pouvoir créer des emplois on est très
content c'est vrai qu'en post en eau
annonce on est beaucoup beaucoup de
candidatures et c'est là on s'est rendu
compte que dans le contexte actuel j'ai
quand même un souci avec beaucoup de
gens qui postulent et on s'y attendait
pas merci beaucoup je raisonne à londres
d'avoir été avec nous pour le début de
ce club de la presse ce début du club de
la presse 2021 les autres journalistes
vous rester avec moi nous allons
poursuivre cette émission et faire un
point à présent sur les dernières
mesures annoncées le 14 janvier par jean
castex
et grégory canal et nous a rejoint pour
la suite de ce club de la presse bonjour
grégory besoin de tv 78 le gouvernement
a donc fait le choix d'un couvre-feu
avancé à 18h pas de confinement
généralisée comme au printemps dernier
en tout cas pour l'instant
cela suffira-t-il à freiner l'épidémie
une chose est certaine il va falloir
s'adapter une nouvelle fois nous
retrouvons dans un commerce yvelinois
célia gars de son go pour la rédaction
de tv 78 bonjour c'est bien oui
exactement pas d'exception pour les
commerçants wilfried qui devront fermer
leurs portes à 18h alors je me trouve
dans la boutique
armand thiery situe à montigny le
bretonneux avec jasmine joseph bonjour
vous êtes la responsable de la boutique
alors première question est ce que vous
comprenez la décision gouvernementale
oui on comprend 18 heures on préfère ça
couvre un confinement pardon comment
comment vous allez vous vous organiser
alors là on va mettre on a une réunion
cet après midi avec notre siècle au
supérieur pour voir un petit peu comment
ça se passe si on doit mettre des
personnes en chômage partiel ou si on va
juste réduire another tout simplement
justement est-ce que les les horaires
seront adaptés seront changés peut-être
travailler plus le midi ou le matin
comment comment ça va alors là le
couvre-feu à 20h nous le centre
commercial on n'avait pas changé nos
horaires donc c'était toujours 9h30 20
heures mais c'est vrai qu'on perd 2
heures je ne sais pas encore on va avoir
aussi également avec le centre si on va
ouvrir peut-être un petit peu plus tôt
est ce que c'est utile d'ouvrir plus tôt
est ce que les clients ont être au
rendez vous ça on ne sait pas encore
c'était le couvre-feu était quand même
peut-être mieux que 15e confinement est
ce que vous vous avez peur d'un
continent ah oui mon acteur d'un long
confinement je pense que pour mon là
l'esprit des gens sur la situation c'est
assez compliqué en confinement donc oui
on a peur de ça
vous le voyez je les commerçants sont
inquiets mais finalement comprennent et
la décision gouvernementale
je le rappelle il y aura d'un couvre-feu
à 18h généraliser à partir de samedi
merci célia merci également la
commerçante qui répondra à vos questions
donc commercial situé à montigny le
bretonneux et puis je précise pour ceux
qui nous suivent également en ce moment
que cette émission est
disait vendredi matin juste au lendemain
des annonces qui ont été faites par le
gouvernement le 14 donc au soir voilà
pourquoi encore les commerçants sont en
train de voir comment ils vont devoir
s'adapter c'est l'une des conséquences
de ce couvre-feu avancé et puis à
d'autres changements attendus aussi un
c'est la fin du sport au sein des clubs
aussi n'y aura plus d'entraînements les
gymnases vont refaire mais certaines
associations venait tout juste de
reprendre grégory je me tourne vers vous
venez tout juste de reprendre essayer de
s'adapter par rapport aux horaires là un
couvre-feu à 18 heures salle est très
difficile de pouvoir tenir des
entraînements le soir au niveau des
gymnases cette annonce est aussi au
niveau des enfants activités scolaires
et extrascolaires qui vont être de
nouveau interdite à l'intérieur après
les clubs amateurs qu'on a pu rencontrer
on sait que depuis le mois de décembre
notamment pour des sports comme le rugby
ou le football les amateurs ont pu
reprendre dans une pratique encadrée
sans contact par exemple au rugby il n'y
a pas le roi de aux plaquages mais on
peut faire des passes au football pas
d'opposition mais on peut faire des
exercices de passes des exercices
également de tir les clubs se sont
adaptés et des les annonces même de
décembre avec un cours ce qui était déjà
en place à partir de 20 heures ont su
s'adapter on a décalé pour certains
clubs les entraînements au week-end en
journée pour pouvoir quand même tout de
même à avoir une certaine pratique
puisque on parle beaucoup de pratique
sportive et d'entretien physique le
sport au sein d'un club c'est aussi il
ya aussi une vocation sociale beaucoup
nous ont dit au cours des nombreux
reportages que leur club de foot leur
club de rugby est une deuxième famille
et que ça pouvait manquer quand il n'y
avait pas d'entraînement il ya plus de
lien il ya plus de contacts et c'est
tout réduit au strict minimum forcément
ça une incidence aussi pour les autres
journalistes qui sont à noter avec nous
pour pour ce club de la presse comment
vous avez ressenti comme encas l'analyse
vous faites des différentes annonces qui
ont eu lieu le 14 janvier par le
gouvernement
plus que moissac avec le thème de mon
sujet ensuite il est vrai il est vrai
que bon
il y avait il ya pas une surprise on
savait ce avait été annoncé dans la
presse
en un mot c'est ça semble être concret
donc pas de surprises et ce bricolage
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
très difficile a parfois à comprendre on
voit que le gouvernement ait perdu et
bon sang bleu ça semble normal parce que
les chiffres évoluent tellement avec ses
variantes qu'il était beaucoup question
y lire sud-africain britannique et ça
pose des questions pour la suite parce
que bon papa on peut pas avancer quelque
chose qui n'est pas encore acté mais il
semblerait assez évident que ces mesures
là vont durer combien de temps est-ce
qu'on va pas aller vers un nouveau
confinement je pense qu'il vaut mieux se
préparer tout ça à s'acquitte est
agréablement surpris
mais voilà c'est du bricolage c'est
difficile à suivre chacune des nouvelles
données ou des journalistes on est dans
la presse donc on s'informe c'est notre
métier mais des gens qui je faisais pas
suivre l'actualité 5 ou 10 minutes par
jour peuvent être totalement perdu
aujourd'hui et ça risque de durer encore
une fois certains plus et où ce sport on
rouvre le sport on perd mais le sport ça
dure très peu de temps finalement à la
sortie des vacances
même pour les plus jeunes aussi ont leur
redit que c'est que c'est impossible
on pense aussi aux lycéens et aux
étudiants alors les étudiants eu un peu
plus d'informations sur un début de
recours en présentiel aussi parce que ça
va pouvoir se maintenir ou pas pour les
premières années on est tout à fait
voilà les choses sont un peu compliquées
et puis malgré tout si on peut pas si on
peut parler de la communication qui est
fait tout de même autour il ya toujours
un peu de maladresse j'aurais juste
reprendre cette déclaration du patron de
la république en marche stanislas
guérini juste avant l'annoncé de ce
couvre-feu sur sur 18 heures l'intérêt
c'est de contrer l'effet apéro je suis
pas persuadé que ce soit la meilleure
communication possible que d'expliquer
aux gens couvre feu de 18h comme ça vous
n'irez pas prendre l'apéro parce que
depuis un an les gens bien compris
c'était un petit peu compliqué tout de
même la même manière que l'appellation
commerce mondial
les familles au quotidien vont devoir
mourir pour revenir du travail pour
aller chercher les enfants à l'école
pour aller chercher les enfants à la
crèche éventuellement faire les courses
donc au quotidien ça va être une course
et s'ils n'ont pas le temps de faire les
courses ils devront tous allaient le
faire tout va se porter vers le week-end
et dans le samedi où là on risque
d'avoir énormément de monde donc c'est
ça paraît compliqué encore est ce que ça
sera suffisant comme disait nicolas
on peut en douter sachant qu'à la menace
des deux variantes britanniques et un
sud africain
on se dirige quand même peut-être vers
un troisième confinement interne
nouradine sur la communication qui
doivent être le non respect et surtout
avec le non respect pour rebondir se
disait alexandre forcément s'il y a
moins de temps pour aller faire ses
courses par exemple quitte ou ferment à
18h et qui a une concentration
la vraie question qui va se poser c'est
est-ce que voilà on va pas créer
d'autres clusters est-ce que c'est pas
plus compliqué à faire avait été évoqué
par le premier ministre le fait d'ouvrir
le dimanche pour qu'ils aient plus de
créneaux pour que les gens puissent
aller faire leurs courses en sachant que
dans certaines enseignes il faut être
faut dire la vérité aux six mètres qui
respectent pas les jauges moi même
personnellement en allant faire des
courses parfois rarement j'ai quelqu'un
qui compte le nombre de personnes qui a
voilà on a fait une seule fois ou
distribuer des jetons dans un magasin
mais sinon assez rarement alors au
pouvoir beaucoup de personnes dans les
grandes surfaces
et puis aussi c'est terrible pour les
gamins là qu'il faisait du sport qui
avait repris quand on sait l'importance
aussi sociale de ses activités bah là
ils vont être obligés de rester à la
maison et on en est venu à même pour les
pour les plus grands à faire des cours
de taekwondo j'ai reçu le président de
l'école de taekwondo trappe qui disait
qu'ils faisaient des cours de taekwondo
par visioconférence il dit c'est à dire
que c'est complètement
bon ils ont pas le choix il essaye quand
même de garder un lien mais vous vous
rendez bien compte que faire du sport
par visioconférence bon ça peut être
sympa cinq minutes mais sur le long
terme ça c'est vraiment embêtant sans
parler des problèmes des cantines etc
mais la communication c'est certainement
la chose la plus belle
utiliser du gouvernement et qui fait
c'est pas facile ça je le concède mais
avec une mauvaise communication
malheureusement on va nourrir des
incompréhensions de la rancoeur et on va
nourrir certaines thèses voilà notamment
entendu vaccin ou d'autres choses encore
il semble de communication elle revient
sur ses termes de contrer l'effet apéro
et c'est une des justifications pour
mettre un couvre-feu à 18 heures sachant
que pendant la période des vacances on a
pu voir aussi une rave party qui a duré
trois jours et gouvernement qui arrivait
pas à mettre fin à cette situation et
qui a laissé la fête se déroulait
pendant trois jours donc alors en termes
de communication c'est un peu compliqué
aussi et bien évidemment radine le
disais c'est difficile à gérer au
quotidien forcément un pur gouvernement
et on le voit dans les autres pays il ya
aussi des adaptations qui sont faites en
temps réel voilà malgré tout il faudra
suivre cette situation on verra si le
confinement total revient ou pas et puis
d'autres sujets à suivre ce sera
l'impact psychologique parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un vrai ras-le-bol
qui dit s'installe pour tout le monde
une vraie difficulté quelle que soit la
profession quel que soit l'âge on parle
souvent des plus jeunes
on pourrait aussi penser aux personnes
plus âgées qui ont aussi eu des clubs
des associations dans lesquelles ils se
retrouvent et ne se retrouvent plus donc
ils ont plus de liens et là aussi tout
cet aspect social est compliqué voilà
pour ce qu'on pouvait dire sur les
premières réactions suite aux annonces
qui ont eu lieu je vous le redis hier le
14 par jean castex puisque nous faisons
cette émission le 15 janvier nous
poursuivons ce club de la presse
nouvelle rubrique
à présent nous allons voir les dossiers
à suivre en 2021 dans le reste de
l'actualité et rubrique consacrée
aujourd'hui aux grands sujets à suivant
2021 dans le département chaque média va
à présent nous livrer le sujet qui
mérite selon lui d'être suivi nicolas
kirillovitch pour radio sensations va
débuter avec vous pour vous ce sont les
premiers signes de reprise économique
qui va falloir gaieté vous allez nous
dire pourquoi dans un instant tout
d'abord regardé ce reportage de la
rédaction de tv 78 et qui fait le point
sur la situation actuelle des
entreprises dans les yvelines
cette société de location de matériel
audiovisuel dédié à l'événementiel avait
son activité arrêtée dès le 1er
confinement tout le matériel d'or sur
les étagères puisqu'il n'y a plus de
réunions possibles sur 10
il y avait dix de vie fait pratiquement
huit affaires conclues et tout s'est
arrêté net à partir du 14 mars
plus aucune affaire plus aucun dossier
un plan social a donc dû être mise en
place sur 47 salariés 20 postes ont été
supprimés ainsi qu'une antenne à
toulouse leur chiffre d'affaires a été
divisé par deux en 2019 il avait réalisé
12 millions d'euros seulement 7 millions
en 2020 pour continuer une certaine
activité les salariés ont créé en studio
de 180 m² avec un mur de l'aide dans
leur partie dépôt pour pouvoir le
proposer à la location
ici vous avez un grand écran led qui
permet de faire de la communication des
entreprises leur communication interne
vous avez le derrière mais le plateau
caméra et nous en voyons tout ça sur le
sur internet par le biais du streaming
avec une plateforme digitale ce sont des
nodal les salariés par le biais de cette
plateforme
vous récupérez les flux de
visioconférence par exemple et ça c'est
là la solution dans l'entreprise avec
les hommes parce que ça marche plutôt
bien et on a d'excellents retours de nos
clients mais cela ne suffira pas pour
payer toutes les charges
la société a donc fait appel aux séries
p le centre d'information sur la
prévention des difficultés des
entreprises
on a rendez vous avec trois
professionnels dont un ancien juge du
tribunal de commerce de versailles hall
aura exposé notre notre situation
ils nous ont donné des conseils qu'on a
appliqué ces entretiens ont dit les deux
jeudis par mois en général 50 entretiens
ont été réalisés en une année en 2020 il
y en a eu plus de 80 en 2021 j'ai vu ma
bouche est persuadé qu'il va y avoir un
bon meneur d'autres entreprises en
difficulté vis donc quand il mais qu ils
vont commencer à faire leurs premiers
bilans et leurs premières prévisions
trésorerie mec ça va tomber dans le
rouge
forcément ils vendent bien où va la cgt
prévoit déjà d' instaurer des rendez
vous supplémentaire en 2021 pour gérer
l'afflux des entreprises en difficulté
la situation est donc aujourd'hui
trompeuses les entreprises se
maintiennent grâce aux aides de l'état
de la région du département mais cette
reprise de l'économie risquent d'être du
coup un petit peu difficile nicholas et
il faudra y accorder une attention
particulière
ah oui ça va être je pense le sujet
majeur de
2021 alors on a cru un moment que la
reprise économique c'était après le
premier confinement en mai juin 2020 on
a pensé à la rentrée à cette fin d'année
bon on l'espère avec la vaccination que
ce soit avant l'été ou après l'été ou en
fin d'année 2021 on l'espère en tout cas
pour cette année et ça va être
intéressant à suivre de voir vraiment
les effets de cette crise puisque on l'a
vu dans le reportage et vous le disiez à
l'instant il ya beaucoup d'entreprises
aujourd'hui qui vivent sous perfusion
des aides de l'état quand ces aides vont
s'arrêter parce qu'elles vont s'arrêter
à un moment le plus tard possible
certains espèrent on va voir vraiment
qui qui va résister à cette fille petite
entreprise grand grandes entreprises
et puis le département des yvelines est
assez intéressant à cet égard parce
qu'il ya des grands il ya des grands
pôles tertiaires puis aussi des zones
rurales donc c'est ainsi un département
hybride voir comment chacun chacune des
zones va s'en sortir il ya le secteur de
l'aéronautique de l'automobile qui est
ultra présent sur le département des
yvelines
on sait que c'est des secteurs qui sont
qui sont énormément impacté par la crise
actuelle on a vu le plan de renault qui
a été dévoilée cette semaine et le
rapprochement entre psa et fiat
ça c'est pour les grands groupes mais
les petites structures aussi l comment
vont vos pelles s'en sortir dans les
zones rurales et les restaurateurs les
salles de sport c'est vraiment les
civils je pense à un petit laboratoire
de la france pour voir quelles vont être
les vrais impact de cette crise parce
que parce que on parle aujourd'hui du
déjà de cette crise économique mais je
pense qu'on ne peut pas mesurer
réellement quels seront ses effets
depuis le début on doit bien comprendre
qu'on est dans dans la découverte
presque quotidiennes et la réalité de
janvier 2021 ne sera sûrement pas celle
de septembre 2021 quand l'économie
pourrait redémarrer
donc on va suivre ça au jour le jour un
peu dans l'expectative
à chaque fois et on espère que c'est
triste pour beaucoup d'entre eux ne sera
pas ne sera pas trop importante elle
serait grave c'est sûr elle aura des
conséquences forcément négative on
espère que toutes ses conséquences
seront limitées et tout de même il ya eu
des prêts qui ont été accordés les
entreprises et les prêts
même s'ils sont des prêts à taux zéro ça
reste des prêts donc il faudra que les
entreprises les rembourse
forcément on voit les on voit l'état qui
est très présent encore encore jeudi 14
février bruno le maire qui a qui a bien
qu'eric enfin qu'à continuer à soutenir
les entreprises avec les aides qui sont
et qui deviennent de plus en plus
importante le prêt garanti par l'état
qui va pouvoir être remboursées au bout
de deux ans au lieu d'un an donc on voit
que l'état est là mais mais l'etat sera
pas toujours là il ya un moment on va
revenir entre guillemets à la normale et
je pense que ça risque d'être difficile
pour beaucoup de beaucoup d'entreprises
il va falloir surveiller ça il ya
plusieurs déjà des buts plans sociaux en
tout cas restructurations d'entreprises
alexandre avec cette chute actuelle est
nouvelle vous avez l'occasion de suivre
quelques entreprises déjà où la
situation est compliquée où ils ont du
mal à faire un peu de plans sociaux
restructurer les entreprises
oui notamment dans l'aéronautique et
tous les sous traitants d'airbus est à
l'aise qu'ils vont payer c'est
probablement les pots cassés comme
permaswage comme les agents courent je
suis au plus n'opérer saint-pierre oui
c'est des domaines qui vont être
particulièrement touchés par cette
poussée actuelle
ce sera donc un des sujets à suivre en
2021 autre sujet à suivre en 2021 et
pour poursuivre ce club de la presse la
tenue de nouvelles élections revient
encore et toujours à la politique
régionale départementale
grégory en tout cas en théorie le
scrutin les scrutins et qui ont été
prévues en mars ont déjà été repoussées
en juin 2021
seulement si la situation sanitaire ne
s'améliore pas et bien on pourrait
imaginer que le scrutin soit encore
reporté mais pas forcément en 2022 parce
que 2022 il ya aussi la présidentielle
et les législatives
donc on partirait sur encore une année
supplémentaire
il y aura un point d'étape en tout cas
qui est prévu c'est la clause de
revoyure comme à chaque fois maintenant
ce sera le 1er avril
alors déjà que c'est difficile pour ces
deux scrutins les régionales et
départementales de faire le plein en
général ça intéresse assez peu le public
c'est encore plus difficile si la
campagne ne peut pas se tenir parce que
si on s'achemine peut-être vers un
recond finement vers mars
forcément faire campagne pour le mois de
juin ça va être compliqué peut-être un
mot sur les différentes formations
politiques pour parler des régionales a
tout d'abord un focus sur les régionales
valérie pécresse présidente sortante
sera forcément elle à nouveau candidate
et puis en face audrey pulvar peut-être
aussi le ministre de l'éducation
actuelle jean michel blanquer
et puis il y à la députée de la france
sont soumises clémentine autain voilà il
ya plutôt un casting quatre étoiles pour
ce scrutin la valérie pécresse part
peut-être avec une longueur d'avancé
parce que la crise malgré tout lui a
permis de s'affirmer et de se montrer
dans les médias elle a été assez
présente elle a réaffirmé le poids de la
région aussi je me tourne vers vous
grégory parce qu'on l'a on a souvent
parlé dans le journal c'est souvent
parlé ce scrutin des régionales ça elle
peut le voir aussi valérie pécresse
comme un éventuel tremplin parce que il
se murmure qu'elle pourrait être une
candidate de la droite et du centre aux
prochaines élections présidentielles
après est ce que valent ils abhorrent
alternance ou pas on sait que sous la
précédente mandature celle de jean paul
huchon ps il était resté pendant 17 ans
à la tête de la région ile-de-france la
valérie pécresse se représente comme
têtes de liste dont on peut imaginer
assez mal que qui est une une alternance
pour pour ce scrutin d'autant que vous
le précisez wilfried c'est un scrutin
aussi acquis qui mobilise assez peu
alors peut-être que ce sera l'un des
enjeux de ces prochaines élections avec
des régionales qui en 2015 avait
mobilisé moins d'un électeur sur deux au
premier tour et un tout petit peu plus
d'un électeur sur deux au deuxième tour
si on regarde les intentions de vote en
tout cas les derniers sondages qui date
de la fin de l'année 2020 la présidente
du conseil régional de l'ile-de-france
présidente sortante qui obtenait 32 %
des intentions de vote devant audrey
pulvar 17 % et jean-michel blanquer
s'il confirme sa candidature bien sûr
15% l'enjeu pour la gauche fera de
s'unir forcément
et encore cette thématique là et puis à
grégory vous avez mentionné ce rebond ce
tremplin possible pour valérie pécresse
pour ensuite devenir président pourquoi
pas candidate à la présidentielle gérard
larcher en tout cas lui pourrait lui
apporter son soutien et il nous l'a déjà
dit et puis pour l'instant pour la
campagne il est à fond sur les
régionales derrière valérie pécresse
il est président de son comité de
soutien on va l'écouter dégagé avec elle
autour d'elle c'est le rôle d'un
président de comité de soutien je veux
dire quelques éléments du projet qui
doivent être des projets partagés
nous ne devons pas oublier que l'île de
france est aussi un département comme la
seine saint denis avec d'immenses
difficultés et bien les réponses que
nous devons apporter
elles doivent s'adapter à chacun des
territoires mais elles doivent est une
marque commune celle de notre région
celle de ses responsabilités avec
notamment la dimension économique est
derrière la crise économique
la région sera un acteur majeur et si le
plan de relance réussie il ne réussira
qu'à une condition qu'ils soient des
concentrés au niveau de la région qu'au
niveau département et au niveau des
communes
là encore la région ile-de-france sera
particulièrement intéressante dans le
cadre de ces régionales puisqu'on l'a vu
que ce soit les ténors aux niveaux
nationaux que sont gérard larcher se
soit encore même gouvernement si jean
michel blanchard se présente vont tous
impliqués dans cette campagne il ya un
autre scrutin alors là ce sont les
départementales peut-être moins d'enjeu
je me tourne vers les autres
journalistes du département aussi
scrutin assez peu ouvert sur ces sources
avancent assez peu en disant ça j'ai vu
que je vais prendre la parole
c'est vrai que bon en 2000 en 2015 si
c'était bien la dernière année des
élections départementales bancs de la
droite avait tout raflé
on pouvait le présupposé on pensait
quand même que la gauche allait garder
au moins un canton où deux là c'est vrai
qu'il ya quand même peu de chances que
les choses évoluent dans un autre dans
un autre sens puisque lrm n'est pas s'y
implanter que cela dans le dans le
département qui profitent pas de
l'actualité la gauche et est désunie bon
latéral et les yvelines ça toujours été
compliqué pour pour la gauche est-ce
qu'ils vont réussir à récupérer un
canton si j'arrive à s'allier ou pas
peut-être mais c'est vrai que les choses
vont pas changer d'un point de vue
fondamental le département des yvelines
personne ne prend de risque en disant
qu'il restera à droite est bien ancré à
droite
à la fin du scrutin de juin il se
maintient il faut dire que c'est une
élection qui qui mobilise encore moins
les électeurs
oui aux élections régionales parce que
c'est pour les gens ça repart et encore
moins concret et du coup ça favorise
souvent les sortants on rappelle aussi
qu'il y avait pendant nombreuses années
cette question de fusionner ces deux
assemblées la région les départements
pour justement faire un peu plus de
clarté dans ce millefeuille comme on
l'appelle à chaque fois des des
institutions ça n'a pas été le cas si
elle scrutin ou pas en juin grégory
lorsque je voulais dire c'est que en
plus si on prend des précédents curseur
celui notamment des élections
municipales qui se sont déroulés l'année
dernière on se pouvait s'attendre
peut-être de l'alternance à une plus
grande implantation nicolas parler de la
république en marche au niveau local
finalement on n'a vu qu'une grande
majorité de maires et on sait que ce
département des yvelines est
majoritairement ancré à droite une
grande majorité de maires a été confirmé
alors de ce scrutin donc on peut
s'attendre co départementale ont soit
sur une même cas de figure au sein de
l'assemblée départementale donc pierre
bédier qui devrait se représenter
devrait rester majoritaire seule
opposition et quelques voix dissonantes
qui se font entendre son au sein même de
la majorité de droite 1 j'ai en tête
notamment
c'est peut-être un peu l'enjeu voir un
peu comment les choses se passeront mais
ils vendent val qui est le président du
parc national naturel régional sur la
vallée de chevreuse qui est le plus
grand opposant à pierre bédier au sein
de l'institution et pourtant ils sont de
la même famille politique
restons sur
les élections et les élections
municipales que vous avez mentionné on
pensait en avoir fini avec les élections
municipales nouradine ce sera pas
forcément le cas du côté de trappes
pourquoi cela oui effectivement vous
n'appelez pas oui vous avez parlé sur
vos antennes également wilfrid la
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne qui a rejeté
donc les comptes de campagne de délire
ab au mois de décembre dernier
mises en cause dont une utilisation de
l'association coeur de trappes à des
fins électorales ça c'est le reproche
notamment aux candidats rabais de s'être
un petit peu trop montrer d'avoir trop
utiliser son association dans
l'entre-deux-tours notamment par des
actions de solidarité alors les
virements elle précisé le couple
noureddine mais l'entre-deux tours qui a
duré aussi plusieurs mois ce qui
explique aussi cette situation un peu
compliquée et c'est ce que fait valoir
lire avait aussi dit n'allez pas se
mettre en retrait pendant un entre-deux
tours qui a duré plusieurs mois avec la
crise sanitaire où effectivement merci
pour cette précision à wilfrid après ce
qui lui est reproché
c'est pas c'est pas seulement avoir fait
des actions de solidarité mais c'est
d'avoir profité de ses actions de
solidarité
on se mettre en avant et pour justement
faire campagne en même temps que la
solidarité
voilà ça c'est le reproche qui lui est
fait principalement les conséquences
pourraient être très importantes pour
les trappistes notamment alors la
première et la moindre c'est le non
remboursement des frais engagés par le
candidat
bon ça c'est embêtant mais bon c'est
plus un problème financier
le second c'est le deuxième pardon c'est
l'annulation des élections donc faudrait
refaire les élections
quand on voit le contexte dans lesquels
déjà s'est passé le 1er tour dans le
deuxième tour également voilà on s'est
dit que s'il ya encore des élections à
trappes ça risque de ne pas arranger la
fracture qui s'est fait déjà avec ces
élections et puis la troisième c'est
avec d'inégibilité de délire avait donc
pour pour contrats pros du coup ça
créerait une son camp sacré moi je
trouve une sorte d' instabilité au
niveau de la gouvernance alors qu'il ya
des dossiers très importants à suivre à
trappes
je pense notamment à l'enfouissement de
la nationale 10 qui dans les travaux
devraient commencer là dans les jours à
venir
mais il ya encore beaucoup de choses
auraient contexte de proville et voilà
cette situation qui n'est pas réglé à
trappes montre qu'il ya encore des
conséquences importantes de ce qu'on
avait dit pendant cette campagne des
municipales avec une violence en termes
de communication sur les réseaux sociaux
voilà pendant cette élection et je pense
que ça a laissé des marques ce n'est pas
encore terminé et preuve en est ce
recours qui a été initiée par moscou et
puis si nouveau scrutin il y à quels
seront les candidats aussi on n'aura
forcément pas un remake de ce qui s'est
passé
sur le 2020 vous parlez de la situation
d'ali rabaisse kaufmann nasro lui serait
impliquerait en tant que tête de liste
rien n'est moins sûr on a bien vu qu'il
avait pris un petit peu ses distances
avec en tout cas l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines il est plus
vice-président de cette agglomération il
l'était sur la précédente mandature il
s'est rapproché beaucoup plus et s'est
impliqué encore plus au sein de la
région au sein de la majorité de valérie
pécresse
il sera dans doute pas très impliqué
pendant la campagne justement des
régionales peut-être mustapha allaoui
avec qui il avait fait alliance serait
lui candidats sont les noirs dina
musicale existait effectivement oui
alexandre disais à l'instant que
peut-être que guy malandain se
représenterait si j'ai bien entendu je
pense que guy malandain serait plutôt en
retrait si on devait refaire des
élections quoique en politique on ne
sait jamais mais non non non non moi
pour je suis pas d'accord avec vous
wilfrid je pense que othman nassr où il
est resté dans le conseil municipal de
trappes même s'il a quitté
l'agglomération et je pense que s'il y
avait des élections il repartirait quand
même en tête de liste toujours avec le
même duo avec avec mustapha allaoui bon
là on est en train de faire de la
politique fiction parce que le tribunal
et jacques les relations se trouvent les
données sont voilà là on est en train de
faire des nous supputons voilà comme
dirait quelqu'un mais par contre puisque
vous disiez à l'instant que otp 1,1 à ce
trou serait appliquée dans beaucoup sera
impliqué beaucoup dans les élections
régionales
mais pourquoi pas également dans les
élections présidentielles puisque si
valérie pécresse qu'on dit en tout cas
partante pour une pour les élections
présidentielles même si elle n'est pas
forcément la candidate des sondages elle
arrive derrière xavier bertrand
président du conseil régional des hauts
de france voilà elle a quand même une
carte à jouer la droite il ya des
primaires qui seront très ouverte si
primaire il ya bien sûr sauf à aller
chercher à nicolas sarkozy empêtré dans
des affaires comme on l'a entendu
récemment certains qu'ils appellent de
leurs voeux le retour de nicolas sarkozy
en tout cas je suis peut-être que othman
menace poussera voilà aussi amener à
avoir des responsabilités dans la
campagne des présidentielle de valérie
pécresse donc à suivre
ça peut être une année passionnante au
niveau politique mais beaucoup de
politique fiction on est quand même
aussi partie de la situation à trappes
et on a terminé sur nicolas sarkozy
si vous venez de nous rejoindre vous
êtes dire que surplus club de la bresse
qui se poursuit alexandre voulu
intervenir
pour compléter dire quelque chose non je
ne voulais juste te dire que après son
échec aux municipales on imagine mal du
malandain revenir et se relancer dans
une nouvelle campagne est donc ça
pourrait rebattre les cartes aussi ça
ferait du coup la gauche partir et moins
divisée dans cette élection sur la
situation à trentels croire terminée oui
pour rebondir sur ce que disait
alexandre juste en ligne petites phrases
beaucoup de commentateurs disaient aussi
qu'après son échec aux municipales
guy malandrins ne siègerait pas au
conseil municipal qu'il laisserait la
place à ces à ses suivants sur la liste
ça n'a pas été le cas il est là et il
est très présent donc audit cette
fiction à suivre et ali rabais et ils
confieront ouvrage propose juste pour
conclure cette séquence de l'écouter lui
en tout cas ils imaginent que tout cela
reste de la politique fiction et qu'il
n'y aura pas de nouvelles élections
le verdit des urnes la trappe il a été
clair et net pour ceux qui connaissent
comme moi ont eu le droit électoral
gagner une élection avec 160 et une voix
d'avancé
il ya aucun tribunal qu'il annulera
jamais cette élection et autres m'a même
si vous savez de quang nam ont
d'ailleurs réalisé au final pardon ses
proches qui sont nos campagnes sympa et
évite le recours est destiné vouée à
l'échec
mais il mène une forme de guérilla pour
détourner l'attention des trappistes des
vrais sujets c'est à dire les réformes
que nous menons et qui me préoccupe moi
et mon équipe au quotidien moi je
m'occupe des vrais problèmes et des
difficultés que rencontrent les
trappistes et je tente de trouver des
solutions au quotidien pour défendre les
locataires face aux bailleurs pour faire
en sorte que ici des gens et du
chauffage tout simplement dans leur
appartement l'hiver ce n'est pas le cas
partout pour faire en sorte que le
projet d'enfouissement de la route
nationale 10 aboutisse pour faire en
sorte également qu'à l'école des enfants
et de meilleures conditions de réussite
voilà mon escrime au cul pendant que les
autres multiplient les recours aux
tribunaux mais vous ne vous inquiétez
pas les tribunaux vont nous donner
raison dans les semaines qui viennent et
nous verrons effectivement le verdict
radi oui je disais c'est un peu la
méthode coué de dire que les comptes de
campagne sont quand même rejeté mais qu'
il n'y a aucune crainte
bon ça assez
c'est la justice qui qui décidera de
cela mais vous voyez les termes qui sont
utilisés des termes très forts un peu
exagéré quand on sait ce qu'est une
guérilla voilà donc comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure par rapport à ces
élections municipales il ya encore des
traces et ça se sent dans le vocabulaire
qu'ils utilisent et de parcs de huy de
parts et d'autres tout à fait et puis
pour cette séquence qui est extrait d'un
entretien politique menée il ya quelques
jours avec ali rabais sur les minutes
précédentes alliera belle faisait aussi
le parallèle sur le duo mustapha
larbaoui othman nasro et comme étant les
donald trump locaux comparé à l'image de
ce qui s'est passé au au capitole aussi
donc on voit bien qu effectivement on
est sur une situation électrique on va
qualifier ça comme ça du côté de la
ville de trappes voilà allez on va
laisser retomber un petit peu tout ça et
on va parler d'un sujet plus joyeux
peut-être les jo 2024 vont-ils se tenir
en 2024 ça c'est une autre question s'il
ya encore un nouveau report du côté du
japon ce prochain pays à accueillir en
2021 il ya déjà eu le report en 2020
alexandre pour vous c'est le sujet à
suivre c'est en tout cas le début de les
préparatifs de 2024 pour paris 2024 et
puis yvelines et et puis il ya 50 et en
yvelines et versailles sont concernés
oui parce que les jo de paris donc son
temps en 2024 mais ça se prépare dès
maintenant notamment à saint quentin en
yvelines qui va accueillir quatre sites
olympiques
donc il ya différents chantiers qui
viennent d'être lancés ou qui vont être
lancés dans les mois qui viennent pour
pour être fin prêt en 2024 pour
accueillir les spectateurs du monde
entier
c'est le cas notamment de la gare de
montigny saint quentin en yvelines qui a
entamé d'importants travaux de
réaménagement qui ont duré pendant plus
de trois ans avec notamment des traces
bellator des quais qui nous est rallongé
c'est aussi le cas du coup ci de là la
colline d'elancourt qui accueillera les
épreuves olympique de vtt et du coup qui
va nécessiter d'importants travaux de
réaménagement y aura aussi des pistes
cyclables qui vont être réalisés sur
l'île de loisirs qui vont permettre de
relier le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du cou qui
accueillera les épreuves de cyclisme de
bmx justement à la colline et l'emploi
donc ça ça va être un gros travail et
puis il va y avoir aussi en terme de ces
irrité la réalisation du nouveau
commissariat de l'agglomération de
d'elancourt qui est surnommé depuis très
longtemps c'est un peu un serpent de mer
qu'on appelle le commissariat du futur
et qui doit être réalisée sur i'll en
cours dans la zone des quatre arbres
donc ça va être un gros boulot aussi
puisqu'il va falloir transférer les
courts de tennis il va falloir voir pour
les jardins familiaux tout un travail
qui va prendre plusieurs années
il sera pas de trop et puis en terme de
jeu s'il va y avoir aussi oui en terme
de transports il reste le point
d'interrogation autour du supra ways
sais pas si vous vous souveniez c'était
un projet de deux cabines aérienne de
transport du futur on en a beaucoup
parlé il ya un point d'interrogation
n'en parle plus trop
est ce que ce projet a été ni été mis au
placard on avoir sur les finances pour
réaliser tout cela aussi avec la
situation actuelle il y aura forcément
des arbitrages aussi qui vont qui vont
avoir lieu et là on parle des
réalisations qui sont certes importantes
mais il ya aussi l'adhésion du public il
faudra aussi motivé un petit peu les
saint quentinois les yvelinois autour de
ces jeux olympiques qui vont se dérouler
juste à côté de chez eux il ya des
rendez vous qui était prévu déjà dès
2020 il y avait une journée olympique
qui devait se dérouler du côté du
vélodrome 2021 elle pourrait peut-être
se tenir au mois de juin on verra mais
là aussi ce sera important d'avoir le
soutien de la population et d'avoir une
certaine effervescence comme ç'avait été
un petit peu le cas sur le golf aussi
avec la rider le golf sur la rider et
aussi des arbitrages vous le ferez vous
vous le disiez mais aussi sur sur des
sites parce que on parlait de l'île de
loisirs qui pourrait accueillir une
piste éphémère pour le bmx avec donc les
épreuves de bmx
finalement il se pourrait ça se discute
en tout cas que les épreuves de bmx se
déroule directement au stadium de bmx
qui est juste à côté du vélodrome ce qui
posait problème c'est le toit de ce
stadium vis-à-vis de la retransmission
télévisée
et donc il ya des discussions qui sont
en cours pour permettre
ce tenir ces épreuves sur stadium de bmx
de la presse se poursuit dernière
séquence à présent toujours sur tv 78
sur ado sensations et puis avec nos
partenaires de 7,8 actus.fr r adio
marmite et les nouvelles également
séquence bientôt lane nous avons vu les
dossiers importants pour 2021 à suivre
mais de quoi parleront vos médias locaux
dans les prochains jours grégory on va
débuter avec vous on reste dans le
domaine sportif tv 78 consacrer une
large page à au sport féminin
oui car la semaine prochaine c'est
l'opération sport féminin toujours s'est
initié par le csa le ministère des
sports alors cette opération elle se
déroule du 17 au 24 janvier son objectif
bien sûr promouvoir le sport féminin sur
les antennes et les ondes des médias
français étaient les 78 a décidé de se
mobiliser en proposant la semaine
prochaine si on parlait sport spécial si
on parlait sport c'est cette émission de
talk que vous retrouvez deux fois par
mois sur télé 78 à laquelle j'ai le
plaisir de participer de régulièrement
en tant que chroniqueur cette fois-ci
mickaël millero et patrice carmouze
auront des invités exceptionnels avec
eux des bords à la source elle est
joueuse du paris 92 c'est un club de
handball actuel 4e de la d1 féminine
claire arnoux que vous avez peut-être
déjà vu sur bin sport et les
journalistes sur cette chaîne allait
présentatrice de l'émission salon vip
lui aura également nathalie sonnac y est
membre du csa et puis marie françoise
porteront vice-présidente du plan de
féminisation à la fédération française
de cyclisme
les thématiques au cours de cette
émission l'image les moyens ou encore la
visibilité qui sont donnés aujourd'hui
au sport féminin et c'est donc la
semaine prochaine sur t&d 78 tout comme
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale que
vous retrouvez bien sûr au cours de nos
journal de la rédaction
la semaine prochaine plus précisément ce
sera le mercredi
si vous avez le jour précis j'ai plus
les jours mais si je vais vous le donne
et danser juste pour préciser que cette
émission bien sûr se déroule sur
l'antenne mais est aussi en replay sur
notre site internet si vous suivez ce
club de la presse avec un léger léger
différé ou avec un petit décalage
voilà je voulais se retrouver là si vous
avez le temps mercredi 18 19 ça sera le
mercredi 20 janvier à 20h sur tb 78
merci et merci également aux autres
journalistes de ne pas nous avoir aidés
chef cette date
c'est ce grand moment de solitude
s'installer alexandre de votre côté ce
sera le corridor écologique de
coignières sur lequel vous allez revenir
oui parce que cronje contrairement à ce
qu'on peut croire ça n'est pas qu'une
grande zone commerciale avec des
centaines de commerces
c'est aussi celle des terres agricoles
et donc la ville tente de préserver cet
art et l'école justement à la acquis
plusieurs parcelles en vue de réaliser
des projets agricoles dans les mois et
les années à venir et des appels à
projets qui vont être lancés avant enfin
de faire venir des tarifs d'heure des
maraîchers de cultiver des fruits et
légumes bio et de rendra donc ces
terrains leur vocation agricole et dans
ce même état d'esprit la villa et qui
aussi six parcelles dans la zone
d'activités de paris ouest
le but c'est d'éviter de l'urbanisation
et tenter de préserver une sorte de
moment pour le dire une coulée verte une
sorte de corridor écologique dans cette
zone où des promoteurs ou des
entreprises étaient intéressées pour
réaliser notamment des parties de plus
en plus de communes qui voit là et au
cours de ce monde on va le voir se
mettre clairement au vert un pouce et
écologistes ou pas en tout cas il voyage
beaucoup de zones préservées de plus en
plus c'était aussi une attente des
électeurs en attendant de lire ce sujet
prochainement les nouvelles sont en
kiosque pour la mi-janvier avec le maire
de versailles à la une il évoque lui ces
projets 2021 vous découvrez cette union
quitte les yvelines avec radio
sensations on va parler d'europe
votre média nicolas les partenaires de
la semaine franco allemande
oui alors c'est on va organiser plus tôt
deux semaines de sur l'amitié franco
allemande
à partir du lundi 18 mois j'ai la bonne
date cette fois ci contrairement à vous
et essayez dans le fil de la journée
franco allemande et qui est le 22
janvier donc ces deux semaines spéciales
sur l'antenne pour mettre à l'honneur
cette amitié compte c'est si
particulière il y aura des interviews
reportages témoignages d'eurodéputés
députés aussi de deux chefs cuisiniers
qui qui cuisine de des plats français et
allemands dans des restaurants parisiens
notât
et ça permettra d'en savoir plus sur
cette amitié franco-allemande si
importante que ce soit d'un point de vue
institutionnel et politique moi aussi
d'un point de vue historique culinaire
culturel aussi parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'échangés qui se font aujourd'hui donc
c'est à partir du lundi 18 tous les
jours à l'antenne de radio sensations à
des pastilles spéciale sur le sur le
sujet c'est en partenariat avec le fonds
citoyen franco allemande et il y aura un
week-end spécial les 30 et 31 janvier où
là c'est toute la journée on parlera de
cette amitié franco-allemande et je
crois qu'on a un extrait à voir et à
écouter d'ailleurs à ce propos pourquoi
pourquoi ici strasbourg pourquoi les
institutions
une partie des institutions européennes
se trouve à strasbourg je crois à
nouveau il ya une raison historique je
crois que les relations entre la france
et l'allemagne ont été en était toujours
marquée par la turbulence et même la
violence dans le passé et je crois que
c'était symbolique si c'était un choix
symbolique très important en 49 de créer
cette première institution européenne
ici à strasbourg à la frontière entre
les deux pays à la frontière où il y
avait des milliers des millions de
jeunes gens qui qui ont perdu la vie
dans les siècles précédents et qui
maintenant représente 7 ce symbole de
cette coopération entre la france et
l'allemagne mais avec avec avec eux
aussi avec d'autres pays européens
voici un extrait d'une des séquences à
découvrir à l'antenne de radio
sensations et vous l'avez dit à partir
du 18 voilà on a bien retenu la date
merci merci nicolas noureddine de votre
côté c'est la vaccination dont il sera
question sur l'antenne de marmite sur
radio marmite 88,4 vous allez revenir
sur cette réticence du public quel que
soit l'âge quelle que soit la catégorie
socioprofessionnelle aussi à se faire
vacciner
juste avant de vous laisser la parole
écoutée d'ailleurs sur cette réticence à
la vaccination
le docteur olivier pajot ils
intervenaient
il ya quelques temps sur quelques jours
pardon sur notre antenne de tv 78 il y à
des personnes qui se posent des
questions et je crois que dans la
stratégie vaccinale global ce sur quoi
il faut insister c'est évidemment les
sujets techniques l'organisation
pratique mais probablement aussi la
l'information prendre le temps
d'expliquer aux gens le les deux
questions qui reviennent le plus souvent
et qui inquiète et y compris des
soignants c'est comment at on pu
fabriquer un vaccin en une année
seulement - mène qu'une année et qu'est
ce que c'est que ce nouveau vaccin arn
dont on ne sait pas grand chose alors
les réponses on peut les donner là elles
sont assez simple quand tous les
laboratoires de recherche du monde
travaille quand même temps sur un sujet
dans les vaccins et développé en moins
d'un an plus tôt que en quelques années
ça c'est la première réponse et puis le
vaccin à rennes en réalité ça fait une
dizaine d'années que c'est c'est connu
et c'est même éprouvé mais dans d'autres
indications qui sont à la cancérologie
donc les réponses on les a mais ce temps
de l'explication de la pédagogie que
l'on doit faire et y compris auprès des
soignants il est il est absolument
fondamental et il doit absolument être
intégré dans la dans la stratégie de
communication elle est docteur olivier
pajot qui intervenait dans le 7-8
société consacrée à la vaccination sur
tv 78 et donc sur radio marmite vous
allez revenir sur cette réticence et
essayer de comprendre j'imagine aussi un
petit peu pourquoi oui effectivement
wilfrid c'est vrai que les chiffres de
des différents sondages qui ont pu être
faits sur les personnes qui souhaitait
ou non se faire vacciner en france était
assez inquiétant même si ça remonte la
ces derniers temps puisqu'on était à
moins de 50% de françaises français qui
se disait prêt à qui disent être prêts à
se faire vacciner
là on est remonté à 54 % de personnes
qui seraient favorables à la vaccination
du colorado occasion de répondre
justement à toutes les questions que les
auditrices résultats peuvent se poser
sur le vaccin avec des questions
qu'originale par exemple
est ce que si on est en période
d'incubation du coc vide
est ce que oui ou non se faire vacciner
qu'en est il des ferments 5 par ailleurs
parce qu'elles peuvent se faire à tirer
la pipe toutes sortes de questions aussi
que les gens se posent sur le côté
pratique mais également répondre aux
côtés un petit peu scientifique sur
comment fonctionne un vaccin
qu'est ce qu'un vaccin arn corps et ces
voix-là d'éclairer un petit peu de
public sur ces questions et on voyait
aussi un couac de communication c'est
compliqué date d'un fort mais aussi
autour de tout ça on incite les gens à
aller se faire vacciner on leur demande
de prendre rendez vous sur une plate
forme aussi je pense aux plus de 75 ans
puisqu'on et mi-janvier et c'était les
personnes qui étaient aussi concernées
la plateforme ne fonctionnait pas au
moment du lancement on a expliqué qu'il
y avait assez de vaccins et qui n'en
arrivait beaucoup et puis après on a
expliqué que le nombre de vaccins pour
les soignants ont été réduits pour
laisser de la place aussi aux autres
voilà donc à beaucoup d'interrogations
il faut lever ce voile l'un et ce sera
en partie faite sur l'antenne donc de
marmite dans les prochains jours merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce club de la
presse merci norad même alexandre
nicolas merci grégory également le club
de la presse le premier pour cette année
2021 se termine on se retrouve le mois
prochain sur tv 60,18 radio sensations
toujours avec marmite fm et puis 7,8
actus.fr les nouvelles à bientôt
[Musique]